hey what's up guys my name is achana
welcome back to another
devlog and we did not have a hazel
devlog last week
i apologize for that i was very busy
working
and perfecting there's some exciting
things happening with hazel over the
last few weeks and today i want to show
you
something that i've basically been
working on almost non-stop for the last
two weeks
something that might seem relatively
simple but in my opinion it's very
difficult to get it
completely right and i think it's
honestly one of the most important
things for a renderer
which might be a big call but i just
hopefully this video will kind of allow
me to explain to you
why i think that is so during the last
devlog which i will
link up there we talked about lights i
talked about how we added
uh four plus rendering into hazel so
that we could have all of these point
lights
everything was looking a lot more
beautiful but
there were just a few things missing and
that has to do with how light
actually works in the real world and how
we kind of interpret
the intensity of light when we look into
the world with our own eyes or with a
camera a huge part of how we gauge how
bright something is
is by something called light bleed now
what light bleed is
is basically when we look at something
or when we take a photo of something and
there's quite a bright light source
the actual light when it hits either the
camera sensor or our actual eyes
i mean it kind of like bleeds over the
top of everything else and this is
something that games have also
been doing for a while it's called bloom
so what bloom is
and i mean bloom can be a lot of things
and it has been done
very differently over like the last 20
or so years but
basically bloom is a way for us to kind
of simulate that natural effect of light
bleed
by just keeping track of what is
excessively bright or brighter than a
certain threshold
and then kind of making it bleed over
the top of everything else
it's also the basics of how emission
works and how we can actually have
materials
that appear to emit light even though
they might not actually be emitting
light into the real world unless we
actually have like
you know global elimination or other
kind of techniques like that
they will appear as if they are emitting
light because they kind of are also
contributing to the bloom without this
effect
i have to say it's very difficult to
write a renderer that
in my opinion looks good i think that
this is like
it's almost it's almost underrated and
that's
a big call because throughout like the
history of games there have been a lot
of examples of games pushing this way
too much
and having like excessive bloom i mean
the first game that comes to mind is
oblivion oblivion i think
or like all those kind of playstation 3
error games i think a lot of them push
bloom a little bit too
a little bit too much it's also very
common to use bloom with an hdr pipeline
now you don't technically have to
there's no reason why you have to
use bloom in an hdr pipeline but it kind
of makes more sense because when we have
those values that exceed one
we can kind of use that energy to kind
of
smear it across our screen and a lot of
this might not make much sense but we're
about to dive into hazel
and actually take a look at this in
action i was very pedantic about this
effect in hazel
i wanted to make sure that this was as
good as it could be
because as i mentioned i think it's
extremely important for scenes and i
have to say i am very pleased with the
result
now i'm not going to go into like a
technical deep dive of how i did this
if you guys want to see a technical deep
dive like i'll open up render doc and
i'll show
everything basically um as well as like
all the techniques i gathered and my
research into this and all that let me
know in the comments section below and i
will make that video
i actually actually kind of want to
because i think it's a it was quite an
interesting journey this is going to be
more of like a video where i actually
show it in action
um and it'll be like a fun time there
but i will say that hazel
processes all of its bloom inside a
compute shader instead of kind of doing
it the
potentially traditional graphics
pipeline way i think it's
it's quite common these days to actually
start moving a lot of post-processing
effects to compute shaders because i
think that
that makes a lot of sense and of course
running it in a compute shader
also unlocks a lot of extra performance
essentially for your engine
anyway let let's dive in to hazel we
have an absolutely
blank scene here which should be uh
pretty interesting to look at now i i'm
going to move this down here because i
know the face cam is kind of in the way
so we have seen render settings which
have some bloom settings that we're
kind of going to be focusing on and i'll
just take you through
essentially how it works and what it
looks like so we have a blank scene as i
mentioned let's go ahead and
add some stuff to it so maybe we'll
start off with a
cube and a plane
uh and maybe i will add a directional
light okay
so this is pretty a pretty simple setup
we'll get rid of the grid as i mentioned
bloom is
is on by default so if we make this
light
excessively bright you can see it starts
to have this kind of glow effect because
when we look at this light it's so
bright that it starts bleeding onto
pretty much everything i have to say
that this effect starts looking pretty
cool
if we play around with like some point
lights uh maybe i'll make this one a
little bit smaller
and if we uh play around with some
colors as well so maybe i'll make this
one red
i'll beef up the intensity and the
radius you can see that it starts to
look pretty cool
we can obviously combine this with like
many other lights and many other
colors like this
[Music]
maybe i'll make it blue i like making
things blue and red because we get
a nice kind of pink in the middle which
looks pretty cool
and you can see that like the scene
immediately looks i think a whole lot
cooler because we have this kind of glow
going off if i turn off bloom as an
example
i mean look at that like doesn't that
just look like trash
i mean on off now you could argue this
is too much but of course you have all
of these settings here so we have a
threshold this is basically
that basically means anything above this
threshold will be kind of considered
too bright to handle without light
bleeding so
um anything above the threshold gets
kind of put into the bloom pipeline
so if i bring this down we'll get more
bloom because
even darker kind of areas are considered
to be blooming
um but then we could also increase this
and then it needs to be like
above 2.2 you could say units of light
energy
to actually be affected by bloom but
then we can also kind of dampen this by
using
the knee there's also an up sample scale
which has to do with how like
up the up sampling actually happens
there's an intensity
which is basically just the way that it
gets composited back into the main
texture
so you can kind of reduce this and it
will just not appear as bright
or you can increase it and it will be
even brighter
and then there's actually also a dirt
texture which we'll talk about a little
bit later
so that's the basics of kind of how you
can use
light and all of that for bloom if i add
a skylight as well maybe i'll make it
dynamic this is probably going to be
going to make things very bright let me
just dim that skylight a little bit
and maybe set it to be like a different
um
time of day you can also you can kind of
start to see how this can
um start looking a little bit more like
a more realistic scene
in daylight and also one thing i might
do is um exposure is also obviously tied
into this so you can
overexpose things under expose things if
we start to underexpose things
you can see that we get back a lot of
that detail so in other words when this
was very bright
it looks very white and it
obviously that kind of color will come
back if you lower the exposure
one of the benefits of an hdr pipeline
now this would this would actually go
fantastically with auto exposure
or some kind of like adaptive exposure
but we don't have anything like that yet
although i probably will add something
like that in the future
okay so let's let's kind of get rid of
that skylight maybe
and we'll talk about emissive materials
so another cool thing
with this so if i delete um let's delete
the point lines
is we also as a result of having a
balloon pipeline we can now do
emission or emissive materials so if i
go into the materials down here
and then maybe let's change it to like
green or something like that
if i start to increase this emissive
parameter
you can see we actually kind of get a
material that
is emissive it emits light now it
doesn't actually emit light
you might notice that if i bring it down
it's such a it's such a cool illusion
though that it
really almost looks like it does i mean
if i bring this down here
it looks like it's emitting light now
it's not it's just the bloom like if i
disable bloom
this looks like trash right i mean it's
clearly kind of not being shaded the
same way
like if i set this back to zero you can
see we can we can't see anything here
so it is kind of still emitting light in
a way but it's just without bloom you
can't really
see that effect at all um compared to
like what it is there
which is uh obviously a big difference
now it's very easy to actually
make this emit light if you want to um
you could simply
like add a point light and parent it to
this object alternatively you could even
add a point light
to the actual entity cube so if i just
add a point light over here
and then i'll set it to be like the same
color and then maybe i'll
decrease that radius i don't know why
the default radius is so high
and then up that intensity then you can
see that we
kind of have a bright cube here and if
we had like
is that like maybe a sphere if we had
some other kind of
um objects in the scene that could
actually catch some of that emitted
light you can see that it actually kind
of gets tinted
green like that because we are actually
in fact
um emitting light now because we have a
real point light
and again just for comparisons bloom off
and bloom on huge difference and again
might be a lot
maybe you can reduce like the emission
or
reduce the intensity if you think that's
a little bit too much
but um yeah i think it's pretty cool and
it definitely gives a lot more kind of
creative control now this scene is the
audio demo scene which i thought i would
also kind of demo
this is quite a quite a bright kind of
dynamic sky that we have over here you
can see how it's kind of bleeding
over all of this if i disable the bloom
this is quite like a
sharp edge you don't get any of that
light bleed but with the blue enabled
you
obviously see the light bleed
if we hit play we can obviously walk
around this scene i'll turn the grid off
it looks pretty nice
it's also pretty easy to like take this
cylinder for example
and let's like stretch it out maybe make
it a little bit smaller
and suddenly we basically have ourselves
if i delete that point like because the
icon is
a little bit annoying we basically have
like a lightsaber
there we go so yeah so we can now do
lightsabers in hazel as well which is
pretty cool
now as i mentioned earlier we also have
this kind of dirt texture
now dirt is uh is basically like a
little bit of like a smudge overlay that
you might have on your camera lens
a lot of games do this i mean off the
top of my head i just remember like all
the suppression effects and stuff in
battlefield 3
they used to always chuck on like a bit
of a a dirty kind of
lens texture unreal engine actually has
some pretty nice documentation on this
so there's a bloom dirt mask this is
just under there like
bloom kind of um documentation page
and you can see what that is and then
you can just add it here and they've
actually got one here
so if we try and plug this one into
hazel
so here we are our kind of dirt mask
then you can see
if you pay attention to like these areas
you can there's also an intensifier so i
can just increase that and make it
like really crazy but you can see that
we get these kind of smudges now they
only apply to areas that are in bloom so
if i look up at the sky you can't see
any of that but when we are in like a
bit of a like bright section so not here
but like
you know where that lightsaber is or
like over here you can kind of see that
texture overlay so it's an interesting
effect i probably wouldn't use it all
the time
maybe in certain areas for certain
scenes it might be cool having it on
all the time is probably not not not the
best idea
but um it's definitely a really cool
effect that i think would be useful
for quite a lot of cases now the final
thing that i wanted to show
is the sponsor demo because i have some
pretty cool things there as well
okay so in the sponsor demo i've
basically just added this kind of
uh let me maybe just turn the intensity
off for now
i've added this sphere which again
appears to emit light
um the sphere itself in this case i
actually added a point light like in the
same position which
um again you don't have to do you can
just add it on the actual entity or
parent it
but you can see what a big difference it
makes whether or not we actually add
that point light so this is
without it actually emitting any light
and then if i bump that back up to like
around six
you can you can see what it looks like
there so it makes a big difference
the sun coming in also reflecting off of
like the taurus
creates that now other kind of materials
in the scene so if we try and find like
one of these for example
um if we make them emit i think that
one's this one over here
this also obviously works for textures
so if i make this emissive
even though we have a texture here and
not a solid color uh it will obviously
still kind of emit light and you don't
have to emit
that much light you can set it to like
one or like you know
two and it will emit a little bit less
light you don't have to go like
crazy with it obviously um but yeah it
also works for textures uh
not just kind of solid colors anyway
let's just hit play and
explore this scene a little bit so you
can see we have
um this kind of um like greenish glow
over here
another thing that i think is quite cool
if we go around to the other side
is uh the actual sky itself um so you
can see that like
the sky because the sky is bright it
kind of creates all of this here
yeah i put a little neon sign as well
that's one of the exciting things you
can do with
uh emissive materials is actually neon
signs which i think is very important
for any game
um but yeah i think the the sky is also
one
one of the things that looks looks quite
good with bloom because if we have like
a generally dark scene maybe
and then we have like this really bright
kind of skylight source
having that be in bloom uh looks pretty
cool if i
maybe pull this over here i might
actually increase the skylight intensity
just a little bit so that we can kind of
see that effect a bit more
so if i jump down here and take a look
at the sky
you can see that all of that kind of
light fill coming in here which
of course looks quite cool and if we
turn the uh dirt intensity
back on then
then there you go we have this kind of
cool uh
bright effect so yeah that's basically
bloom
and emissive materials very important to
have
in really any renderer i think this is
kind of exciting because
there's honestly so many things you
could do with this
i mean even things like fire or
particles are going to look a lot better
because we have this kind of extra light
bleed going on
but even normal scenes with like a
bright sky and
you know auto exposure now which will
turn which will kind of tone that down
when i get around to adding it like
i think all of this um definitely
contributes to having a way more
realistic renderer so yeah i'm really
happy to finally get this in here
if you would like access to hazel and
you'd like to support hazel's
development patreon.com i'll have a link
in the description below
is the best way to support all of this i
say this all the time but of course
hazel would not be here if it wasn't for
all of your support so huge thank you to
everyone who helped
support the development of hazel and
everything i'm doing here on youtube
thank you so much
as i mentioned there are just so many
topics for devlogs running i've got this
massive list so let me know if you want
to see something specific for next time
uh but other than that i've still got so
many new features that i haven't shared
yet so
yeah i will see you guys next week thank
you all for watching goodbye
[Music]
you